with centuries worth of history there
has been plenty of time for sitcoms to
establish long-standing records within
the genre although records were meant to
be broken some have stood the test of
time let's take a look at the sitcom
records that may stand
forever appropriately for a country that
aired the first sitcom on tv britain can
also claim the longest running sitcom in
history in january 1973 bbc one aired
the first episode of last of the summer
wine a roy clark sitcom about three
older men who engage in a variety of
youthful hijinks and adventures in the
absence of spouses jobs or other
responsibilities the first season of the
show wasn't very well received admit it
you're bored already
nevertheless last of the summer wine
like its characters got better with age
and eventually became an institution of
british entertainment as time went on it
seemed impossible to kill surviving the
deaths and departures of major cast
members and the growing indifference of
the bbc it even continued during the
changing tide of public opinion as the
program entered its second third and
fourth decades but in 2010 last of the
summer wine finally went off the air
setting the record officially at 37
years 7 months and 25 days
despite this admittedly impressive
accomplishment it should be mentioned
that last of the summer wine doesn't
entirely deserve its place on this list
why well because this record will almost
certainly be broken specifically by a
certain decades spanning prime time
cartoon which will leave summer wine
with the consolation prize of being the
longest-running live-action sitcom
the show that will likely unseat the
last of the summer wine in terms of
sheer longevity already holds numerous
sitcom records
the simpsons was officially launched in
1989 and it's been going ever since
becoming the longest-running american
sitcom and the longest-running scripted
prime time series of any kind when it
was renewed for its 33rd and 34th
seasons in march 2021 the simpsons
ensured that its total episode count
would be at least 757 if we're being
honest it will probably be a lot more
far and away than most episodes for any
animated sitcom that renewal also meant
that the simpsons will be on the air at
least until the end of 2023 at which
point it will be less than four years
away from the sitcom longevity record
held by summer wine there's no end in
sight for bart lisa homer and marge
after its longtime network distributor
21st century fox was purchased by disney
in 2019 the simpsons arrived on the
disney plus streaming service here it
will presumably remain until it stops
making a profit given the way disney
tends to treat its intellectual property
it's extremely unlikely the show will be
cancelled prior to its 38th year the
simpsons just keeps going smashing
record after record in the process
we are by no means done talking about
the simpsons which among other things is
famous for its guest stars a hallmark of
the show has been the way celebrities
appear as themselves it's a star-studded
roster that includes just to name a few
leonard nimoy rachel maddow lady gaga
and hugh hefner there was a time in the
show's heyday when you weren't really a
celebrity if you hadn't been on the
simpsons with that in mind it's no
surprise that the simpsons hold the
guinness world record for most guest
stars in an animated series of any kind
according to guinness the total number
was 810 as of april 2020 though
obviously the number is even higher now
it would be utterly inconceivable to
imagine another show let alone another
animated show being as guest star
friendly as the simpsons and as
previously mentioned the simpsons is not
going away anytime soon season 33 hasn't
even arrived yet and we already know
that comedian maurice lamarche and nfl
red zone host scott hanson will be added
to the ranks so it seems pretty safe to
say that no tv program will likely ever
have more guest stars than the simpsons
as you might expect a show with the
lifespan and accolades of the simpsons
also has a history of cleaning up at the
emmy awards the highest honor an
american television program can achieve
it won its first emmy in 1990 for the
episode life on the fast lane and would
go on to absolutely crush the awards for
the rest of the decade including stellar
individual years like 1992 in which it
tallied six wins for outstanding voice
over performance and 1998 when it won
emmys in three separate categories while
it never saw that particular level of
dominance again the simpsons continued
to rack up emmys throughout its
existence most recently in 2019 when it
won for an episode addressing themes of
homophobic bigotry called mad about the
toy it was the 11th simpsons victory in
the category outstanding animated
program no other show is won in that
category more than five times
similarly hank azaria and dan
castellaneta have each won four emmys
for outstanding voice over performance
for their work on the simpsons at this
level they're tied for most ever
alongside seth macfarlane
all told the simpsons has set a guinness
world record by amassing 34 total emmy
awards the fourth most of any show in
history no other animated series is even
in the top 10. given the unlikelihood of
any other animated show becoming a
cultural monolith like the simpsons it
seems safe to say that this simpsons
record will also never be broken
now that we're done celebrating the
simpsons let's talk about some emmy
award records set by non-animated shows
first up 30 rock tina fey's lovingly
irreverent business of television sitcom
that aired on and made fun of nbc from
2006 to 2013. despite consistently shaky
ratings 30 rock was beloved for its
lampooning of the backstage workings of
saturday night live and the nbc network
in general so it was appropriate when
faze snl parody of vice presidential
candidate sarah palin in 2008 led to an
increase in exposure and appreciation
for 30 rock this culminated at the 2009
emmy awards in which the show's third
season set the guinness world record for
most emmy nominations for a comedy show
in a single year in addition to
outstanding comedy series which it won
for the third year in a row faye and
alec baldwin were both nominated for
acting along with eight other performers
in guest and supporting roles ironically
faye would win an emmy that year not for
30 rock but for her send up of palin
with three more nominations for
direction four for riding and four in
the creative categories 30 rocks season
3 garnered 22 emmy nominations it's a
number that hasn't been surpassed by a
comedy show in more than 10 years and
probably won't be at all
the record for most any victories for a
comedy in a single season is held by the
most modern show on this list no comedy
has ever done what shit's creek did in
2020 coming off its final season the
canadian sitcom won all seven of the
major comedy awards directing writing
the four acting awards and outstanding
comedy series this is something no
comedy in history has accomplished dan
levy who worked on shit's creek in every
capacity became the first person in
history to win an emmy for acting
writing directing and producing in the
same year throw in a couple of creative
category wins and shit's creek took home
nine emmys a world record for a comedy
in a single season it did all of this
while up against the finales of beloved
sitcoms like modern family and the good
place not to mention the marvelous mrs
maisel which had previously held the
record for most single season wins
how did the shit's creek sweep happen
especially considering it had never won
a single emmy in its five previous
seasons
some have speculated that voters
quarantined in their homes due to covet
19 had spent their time binging shit's
creek on netflix leading to a sudden
swell of support for the show it was a
unique situation that we're unlikely to
ever see replicated
as we've seen there are several sitcoms
over the years that have had a positive
relationship with the emmy awards still
the one with the most total emmy wins
hasn't even been mentioned yet in 1993
cheers one of the most recognizable and
popular sitcoms of all time went off the
air after 11 seasons and 28 emmy awards
but in an almost unprecedented turn of
events the cheers spin-off was arguably
even more successful guilty as charged
frazier followed psychologist fraser
crane who had joined the cast of cheers
in season three frazier hosted a seattle
radio program and interacted with a
delightfully eccentric group of family
and friends the show was a hit at the
emmys from the start it won the award
for outstanding comedy series after its
first season and would go on to win for
seasons two through five making it the
first series to win that award in five
consecutive years by the time frasier
was finished with its own 11 season run
it had racked up a total of 37 emmys
which was at the time the record for a
scripted series of any kind it has since
been eclipsed in that regard by game of
thrones but frazier still holds the
record for sitcoms the simpsons is the
only show that has even a vaguely
realistic shot at beating it nothing
else has even come close though modern
family did manage to tie the five
consecutive outstanding comedy series
wins accomplishment
frasier was anchored by the performance
of its leading man kelsey grammer who
won a record-tying four emmys for his
portrayal of the title character he was
also nominated for playing frasier crane
in both cheers and wings for a time he
also commanded the highest salary in
network television at one point signing
a deal with nbc worth 1.6 million
dollars per episode that record however
was almost immediately broken by ray
romano for the show everybody loves
raymond for which romano got paid 1.8
million dollars per episode by cbs and a
few years later the same network gave
even more to charlie sheen for his work
on two and a half men while sheen's
contract is technically still the most
lucrative per episode deal in sitcom
history context has to be considered he
was only making that amount of money for
the show's eighth season and the last
four episodes of that season were
cancelled after sheen's explosive
falling out with cbs likewise romano's
1.8 million dollars was only for one
season whereas grammer's deal was for
two when you do the math the 76 million
grammar received for the last two
seasons of fraser shakes out to a bit
more than what romano got paid during
his most lucrative contract however it
should be noted that romano also earned
royalties for the show regardless of how
you define highest paid no sitcom actor
since sheen has come anywhere close and
we'd be surprised if it ever happened
again
charlie sheen wasn't the only performer
cbs opened the bank vault for after the
success of two and a half men the show
which was premised on two brothers
charlie and alan harper raising allen's
son jake also holds the distinction of
employing the highest paid child actor
on television of all time angus t jones
who played jake reportedly made 250 000
per episode a number that guinness
recognized in 2010 after an analysis of
tv earnings by the new york post a 2014
article by the post however claims that
by the time jones left the show he was
making considerably more 350 000 per
episode by that time jones had started
publicly disparaging two and a half men
for conflicting with his religious
values the show's tenth season would be
his last as a regular cast member with
the role of the half being taken over by
amber tamblyn for the final two seasons
jones did however make a cameo
appearance in the series finale so maybe
his being the most financially secure
child actor in tv history may have
occasionally overcome his distaste at
the sinful nature of two and a half men
the earning numbers we've looked at so
far are all well and good but there's
only one man who can reasonably claim to
be the highest earning comedian of all
time
it's been more than 23 years since the
legendary sitcom seinfeld wrapped up its
iconic nine year run however when forbes
released the 2020 edition of its annual
list of the world's highest paid
celebrities jerry seinfeld was once
again the highest ranked comedian he
raked in 51 million dollars over the
course of that year that was enough for
guinness at least for the time as they
update that record on a yearly basis but
it's also just difficult to imagine
another comedian ever making more money
over the course of their career than
jerry seinfeld
i don't know how to tell you this but
i'm i'm a funny person
seinfeld has reportedly earned as much
as 400 million dollars per year from
seinfeld syndication royalties alone he
also recently signed a 500 million
dollar deal with netflix for the rights
to the show beyond that though is the
sheer longevity of his comedy career
which he somehow managed to get paid to
reinvent the 2002 documentary comedian
follows seinfeld around the comedy
circuit in the years following the end
of the show that made him famous the doc
hangs on the detail that seinfeld has
decided to completely overhaul his act
and cut out every previous joke and
routine he'd ever told the choice paid
off
not only did comedian make a couple
million dollars followed by his popular
comedians and cars getting coffee series
but his ongoing relevance convinced
netflix to pay him 20 million dollars
for a new comedy special as recently as
2020.
just as it's difficult to imagine any
comedian making more money than jerry
seinfeld it's also difficult to imagine
any network making more money from a
single episode of comedy television than
nbc did on may 6 2004 that was the day
nbc aired the series finale of friends
another sitcom that etched itself into
the hearts and minds of a generation the
show's 10 season run kicked off in 1994
introducing the world to jennifer
aniston lisa kudrow courtney cox david
schwimmer matt leblanc and matthew perry
each of them were reportedly making a
million dollars per episode by the end
due to the program's massive popularity
when it was time to bring friends to its
conclusion after a decade of success it
was clear to everyone that the final
double-sized episode would be a must-see
event for the entire country as a result
nbc sold advertising spots on that
episode at rates unheard of for anything
short of the super bowl every 30 seconds
worth of ad time during those 44 minutes
of tv cost 2 million
which remains a guinness world record
for any television series to this day
as we've seen elsewhere on this list the
fracturing of the television audience in
the era of online media and streaming
services makes it all but impossible
that such a feat will ever be repeated
the sitcom format that most of us are
familiar with involves episodes airing
in 30-minute time slots traditionally it
was 22 minutes of sitcom interspersed
with eight minutes of commercials
occasionally a sitcom will run longer
taking up an hour's worth of airtime or
operating under a different format due
to an alternative revenue model from
standard advertising
still you rarely ever see sitcoms that
are shorter but believe it or not they
do exist and some sitcoms are only a
minute long in 1998 tv land a cable
network dedicated to broadcasting
classic television episodes and movies
introduced 60-second sitcoms they were
tiny stand-alone mini-shows that
appeared in between tv land's
programming and its commercials the
network was brand new having launched in
1996 and hadn't even sold ad space
during its first year
shows in tvland's 60-second sitcoms
lineup included the gaveltons which
chronicled the adventures of an absurdly
litigious nuclear family and all's well
where every episode ended with a police
officer showing up to eat pie
tv land is recognized by guinness as
having produced the shortest comedy show
in history and we dare somebody to try
and break that record
everybody loves raymond and that
includes the greatest sitcom records
today fred garrett who played raymond's
brother robert in the show everybody
loves raymond won three emmy awards for
outstanding supporting actor in a comedy
series beyond his acting abilities and
his skill at poker garrett stands out
for two reasons his deep distinctive
voice and his towering height
standing six foot eight inches tall he
would eventually be recognized by
guinness as history's tallest actor in a
leading role that's not just for sitcoms
according to guinness garrett is the
tallest leading man in any screen medium
he surpasses movie stars like james
cromwell at six foot seven the tallest
actor to ever receive an oscar
nomination as well as both tim robbins
and dwayne the rock johnson at six foot
five sorry apprentice pride fans
although andre the giant was six foot
eleven he was hardly the lead same for
richard keel who was seven foot two but
never a leading man the fact of the
matter is that people as tall as garrett
don't usually become leading men on tv
or in the movies the average male lead
in hollywood stands at about five foot
nine so he will probably be recognized
as the record holder for a very very
long time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]